she's one of the stars of the
oscar-nominated bable Ava Green and Gael
Garcia Bernal
good evening at the heart of any great
film there is a great story where the
long or short it's what you do with it
that comes these four documentaries told
the real stories of people dealing with
very different challenges living in
poverty
coping with aids overcoming physical
handicap and striving to realize a dream
and the nominees for Best Documentary
Short subject are the blood of yangshou
district Ruby yang and Thomas Lennon
recycled life Leslie Iwerks and Michael
Autopia rehearsing a dream
Karen Goodman and Kurt Simon two hands
Nathaniel Kong and Susan Rose bed and
the Oscar goes to the blood of young
hood district by Ruby yang and Thomas
Lennon
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Ruby a the first Oscar
win and second nomination for Thomas
Lennon
thank you everyone
a treacherous profession documentary
film one part of our hearts with remote
villages in an way China the other part
burning to get here Beverly Hills
complicated quite complicated
our thanks to Jing June and Leisha Guan
Joan Ganz Cooney our chinese-american
supporters the star foundation Sheila
Nevins of HBO Jagger Chung ma the whole
Chinese crew and most importantly Xiang
yang who let us film her work conscious
or da Kang Yong Jun Hyuk's easy woman 2
ponyo shishun in case you're wondering
where he's been here he is Jerry
Seinfeld
thank you thank you um
few years ago um I was the subject of a
documentary called comedian which won
nothing and made even less but it was
good it was so good that as a direct
result I have been asked here tonight to
present the award for outstanding
documentary feature and I love
documentaries I find them to have a very
real quality and I know all the nominees
are excited because when you are
nominated you are being told we think
you might be the best might we won't
know definitely until we get you all
dressed up in a room together with all
the other people I ain't on TV because
if by some chance it should turn out
that you are not the best we all want to
see the look on your face when you get
the news I am a huge fan of movies in
general I go all the time I have noticed
in theaters now they're running this
little announcement trying to get you to
pick up the garbage from around your
seat oh okay let me bring my orange
jumpsuit and wouldn't stick with a nail
in it too maybe I'll work my way down
the highway after the credits roll
I'm not picking nothing up I'm the one
that threw it down how many different
jobs do I have to do here there isn't a
greed upon deal between us and the movie
theater people it is understood by every
single person in this room the deal is
you rip us off on overpriced oversize
crap that we shouldn't be eating to
begin with in exchange for that when I'm
done with something I open my hands
not sticking my hand down into a dark
hole and trying to pry out three goobers
that have been soda welded there since
the Shawshank Redemption which is not a
nominee this evening but these five
incredibly depressing movies are deliver
us from evil Amy burg and Frank Donner
an inconvenient truth Davis Guggenheim
Dirac and fragments James Longley and
Johnson oh Jesus camp
Heidi Ewing and Rachel Grady my country
my country Laura Poitras and Jocelyn
Glazer